holy cow wow live Applause on YouTube
has this ever happened before that is
incredible that is amazing I am Dave
Ruben this is the Ruben report we are at
YouTube space LA and we are in the midst
of the greatest gay time ever is this is
has it ever been better for the gays
this is
it okay
all right you guys aren't that impressed
it started you clapped a little and then
you kind of brought everybody along that
was good okay very good uh we got a
great show for you guys we're going to
be uh talking about some LGBT issues I
I've got some great choice gays with me
and uh you know part of what YouTube is
doing right now uh on their Spotlight
Channel they're doing their Proud To
Love campaign and this is where they're
showing uh people talking about who they
love why they love what they love uh and
I put up a video with my grandma and
let's take a look so you're 85 and I'm
35 so we have 50 years old that's a lot
but I don't feel old but you don't feel
old well how do you
feel happy to be alive yeah and did you
learn anything in all these years like
what can you say what can we life is a
mystery it is it is that's what I do you
can't be sure of anything yeah you try
you should be you should be kind yeah
that's the most important thing is to be
a kind person yeah that is be good nice
to people yeah
and and hope for the best do the best
you can and be uh be kind yeah and a few
years ago I told you that I was gay but
you didn't even care I don't remember
you are you gay that's okay with me
that's fine I am that's wonderful if
you're happy that's all that counts yeah
I am what's the difference you didn't
even remember no yeah but you don't care
at all no makes no difference no yeah
not at all but people say that it's a
generational thing that older people
people the older people don't like it
but younger people do but no what do you
think I don't know I think you forgot I
mean I told you we I told you at a diner
I took you after lunch and I told you
well I guess I've known it but I never
think about it it doesn't matter to me
yeah makes no difference not at all yeah
you're a good person that's all count
I'm trying how many people aren't there
in there
stiners how so what's the difference you
know you can be be nice be good person
that's it and that's all it com yeah
really yeah I love you love you too
okay you got a
Sunan
a love
Grandma all right a round of applause
for my grandma elae all right pretty
good way to start the show Okay so let's
get right to it we got some great
panelists first up we've got the gay
pimp himself Johnny
McGovern
he's good that guy he is good next up we
have YouTube sensation Miss Hannah
Hart then from the real lward we have
Whitney
mixer the guy that is giving me a
million dollar smile from AMC chville
Alec
mappa and a second YouTube sensation
because it's all about the subscribers
people Bri
esrig all right guys so we got a lot of
gay stuff to talk about first off are
you guys all comfortable sitting here
gay people this is like a zoo like
they're watching us we got a gay Zoo up
here I thought you were going to ask are
you comfortable being gay I thought you
were well now that you mentioned it I
thought you were going to ask are you
comfortable sitting this close to gay
people yeah cuz I'm not as a lesbian is
that weird for you to sit in between
problematic proximity yeah I would say
there's a testosterone overload but I'm
not sure I think it's I think it's
coming from me yeah so you're welcome
well guys so Doma the big news it has
happened it is over we will be able to
be equal we'll start wearing pleated
pants and be boring that's all we've
ever wanted okay it's great now I
believe that two of our panelists here
are are actually married two of you
are thank
you thank
you thank you not to each other oh no
not to each other but you know the the
Dom thing the the first thing I thought
of because I'm married and we have a we
have an eight-year-old son and we came
back from uh an international trip one
time and we were checking in through
customs you know you come in and you
fill out the forms and the head of
household fills out one form right so we
went up to the Customs counter as a
family this was maybe two years ago and
they said what's this what's this about
I said we're a family says you're
married he says yeah we're married well
we don't recognize that here and my son
was like six years old at the time and
he came up to the counter he goes who's
this he goes it's our son said you
adopted him he goes yes and then he
started backpedaling for being such a
douche like go oh it's not me it's it's
it's it's the law we don't recognize
this year I mean like totally mortified
that he had been rude to two parents in
front of their own kid and now the
minute Doma pass that was one of the
things that's going to change
immediately is that we're going to be
recognized as a family we will be kind
of scrutinized in the same way before
we'll be able to go through customs like
everybody else and that seems like a
kind of a trivial thing but it did
matter those are it didn't feel like the
spotlight was on us like oh you're
different oh you're different and and
less than in this circumstance yeah and
that's the thing I mean all that any of
us want is to feel normal you know what
I mean well I always said you know we're
gay we want the same things but the only
difference is we're gay so we want nicer
things now Whitney you you also are
married I think you got married you got
married in that brief window when Prop 8
wasn't didn't happen yet and there was a
minor moment of no no I did not no and
this is the thing I actually got legally
married in Connecticut then I had a big
wedding in California so now I guess I
need to get remarried to my wife for a
third time again in California I think
there should start like this new uh kind
of like tally system a competition of
how many times a gay person can get
married in how many states as new you
register each time you would totally
cash in oh my God I know God I'm doing
it it's all about the gifts it really is
it's all about the gifts it's all about
the wedding cake really I broke it out
yesterday I broke out my one year Frozen
wedding cake did not wait for it to thaw
and just went for it hard nice nice yeah
in honor of Dom I was like pouring some
of my 40 out for do turning
over all right Johnny you are up I
believe you're single so how does Doma
affect the modern single gay
thank you well look Dave I'm not married
yet but when the time comes for to me to
have my Coming to America style wedding
with elephants vogan ball queens and
artha Franklin coming out from a
reversible aisle that I also walk down
I'm glad that that Extravaganza will be
federally
recognized beautiful beautiful mild
Applause mild Applause y yep yep
certainly worthy of a round of applause
and Hannah what about you are you are
you excited do you have any big plans
coming any lucky ladies we need to know
about
uh you know I mean
what I'm a little on the spot yeah yeah
I asked you five loaded questions at did
um yeah no I uh you know for the first
time in a while I am actually seeing
someone and it's gone pretty great uh
but you know we'll see how it is I live
a very public life so I'm trying to keep
things really slow and casual but then
Doma passes Gotta Get Married quick mean
how many text messages did you guys all
get yesterday are you getting married
free did you get any text mess are you
married you gotta get married believe it
or not it got none no no no
text
bisexual now B you are bisexual so how
do you feel about what happened
yesterday cuz you kind of could have got
married before to anybody to anyone yeah
I mean I have all the options open to me
uh that's great but I I mean my own
personal thoughts on marriage aside I
hate being told what to do so the fact
that I'm allowed to do whatever I want
Now is awesome yeah yeah does it seem
crazy to you guys that these nine sty
people in robes voted on how we're
allowed to love like does the whole
system you know I'm really kind of
astounded every day about how much
anybody gives a exactly because if
they knew what my life was like what my
gay marriage look like it would be if
you tuned into our house if there was
like a cam you would see my husband and
I folding laundry while our kids asleep
after 8:30 watching So You Think You Can
Dance and that that's the big ugab Booga
that's what people are terrified of
crazy I mean there is the whole other
gay sex thing but other than that but um
phenomenal it's it's it astounds me that
we've taking it this far but the great
thing about Domo was and and the prop
eight case was they they presented in a
lawyerly way and they really ask people
what harm is being done to you what harm
will come to you
these marriages and they were they were
supposed to have witnesses four dropped
out two showed up and none of them could
State a case of a way that they would be
harmed in a real concrete way yeah so if
it takes that discussion it takes the
gravity of that discussion to kind of
prove that nothing bad is going to
happen then that's what it's going to
take but there's still people yakking
about it today I think it's a lot about
I recently just went on a tour around
America and I think that we are very
fortunate to live in the bubbles that we
do you know I've always lived in
California or I've lived in New York and
going around the States you really can
see that it's not it's not like how it
is here so it seems so strange to us
that people you know give any shits
about what we do with our lives um but
when you get out there it's just a real
sense of like otherness it's a
difference and it makes people
uncomfortable makes them scared because
it it what it does is it compromises
everything that they believe to be the
same and to be right yeah um which is
you know so where then do we put
religion in this whole thing because
that seems to be the last part of it
that people are fighting with us right
where where do you think we put where do
that argument is that argument even
valid in the Public Square no I don't
think you should put that with anything
like my own personal God likes me no
matter what your personal God is going
to like you no matter I mean it doesn't
matter I I my personal God you know well
I mean we're forgetting that we're not a
theocracy that's Afghanistan right
that's Iran if you want a state that's
run by the church that's where you go
yeah yeah I'd rather a state run by a
bunch of people listening to us frankly
myself that would be that would be
absolutely lovely uh you know it's
unfortunate because as a YouTuber you
get feedback in your comments a lot and
every time you know something gay gets
like brought up people say people do
sometimes get uncomfortable about their
religions and you know I you know I have
my personal beliefs in like God and it
doesn't nothing is jeopardized you know
and I feel that people think you're
automatically by being a happy gay
person you're automatically attacking
their beliefs fundamentally but the
truth is you're not not you know if
you're openly attacking them then yes
and gay Jesus definitely approves of gay
marriage he sparkled it down yesterday
that was a gay Jesus moment for us all
that was a gay Jesus is gay Jesus going
to officiate your wedding gay Jesus is
already RCP to my gay wedding that's so
like him you know he's not GNA go once
he's goingon to go twice he's going to
be in charge he wants to be mea Franklin
all right well I want to stay with this
this part about the haters a little bit
because of course yesterday all this
greatness happens we have you know huge
celebration
in New York and in California all over
the place but our Michelle Bachman and
our Rick santor and our Mike huckabees
were not as thrilled I got a great quote
here from Michelle Bachmann she said
yesterday marriage was created by the
hand of God no man not even a Supreme
Court Justice can undo what holy God has
instituted uh this coming from a woman
who I'm pretty sure has been in a gay
marriage this entire
time did you hear Nancy Pelosi's
response the best response they they
quoted that entire quote they they asked
Nancy Pelosi what do you think she went
who cares who cares could you think of a
less relevant person than Michelle
Bachmann right now I always think that
people that are so staunchly and openly
homophobic are a little gay well I mean
they're totally gay and it's proved
every single time right she has a little
gay in her bed next to her every night
yeah she has she has a big gay a big guy
yeah like yeah well okay so then there
are people like that what do we do with
these people cuz Marcus Bachman is gay
is a fruit cake and it's like what what
do we do what are we going to do they
have they are we going to break up their
marriage they got 18 kids 74 foster kids
he's doing a conversion Camp take it
please they are the least intimidating
people out there I think I mean you look
at them they like will throw something
out there and then run away with their
tail between their legs if you look at
Rand Paul on the on Glen Beck's show the
other day you know he did that very
obvious comparison to uh you know now
that we've made this gay marriage legal
um with Doma uh you know the obvious
analogy about animals and you know hum
now we can marry dogs very quickly can
we can everyone here confirm that you
don't want to marry your dog
or I cannot do that absolutely the
bisexual one can't do it I won't you
will not no not not in this for him guys
this it's hard enough being a lesbian
I'll stick with that though you will
stick with the chicks can you confirm
you will not marry your dog or your cat
or your fish or your lizard 100% will
not I mean I came from a background that
actually believed that pedophilia
bestiality all those things were the
same thing as homosexuality like that
was the environment I grew up in and so
when you hear comparisons like that I
think you're making a good point Whitney
which is that people who are throwing
the stuff out there and then running
away those are the people we don't have
to actually feel uncomfortable around
because they make themselves look like
idiots and they're look look like
everybody's busted right now everybody's
kind of busted on their own ignorance I
think that's what Doma did and what the
Supreme Court cas did is like let's
really talk about this if you really
want to talk about this and talk about
the harm that it's going to do and
what's going to happen and when it came
out that no harm was going to come to
anybody you're busted so now all they
can kind of come up with is nonsense
yeah and and and Indiana the governor of
Indiana is saying that now he wants to
put an anti-gay marriage initiative on
the ballot but now prop a has been
struck down is like we basically said in
the highest court that voting on this is
unconstitutional and to me this is this
is a big wave and it's been Unleashed
and you can't put it back in a little
cup Johnny you marrying your dog you're
giving definely not marry the dog I have
plenty of young gentlemen to lick me on
the side of my ear I don't need to know
all right very good uh one final point
on this what do you guys do because you
guys all live in the digital space and
we're doing this of course from YouTube
what do you do forget the the bachans
and the Santorum and the rest of them
but what do you guys do about just the
online you know these Anonymous haters
now we know that the government is now
watching them so maybe they'll get a
little nicer but forgetting that what do
you do when you're dealing with with
these people I mean there's that slide
over button and delete like it's really
that simple in the in the technology age
you can simply ignore black you know you
don't have to be privy to all that
negativity out there you can select what
kind of you want to hear really
yeah bried do you have a policy on the
haters well I get a lot of hate a lot of
the time but I the thing I like to do
most is just give them a little bit of
love I like to I no well it's true I oh
my God I love everyone everybody's love
it what I like to do to the haters is
whatever they want
exactly I don't know I just like to be
like look like your life seems kind of
miserable I think you could use a little
bit of love so you may hate me but I
love you okaybye yeah that's really I
said I wasn't going to cry that's yeah
somebody that was our kumbai moment
there you go Alex you have a policy well
I think here's the thing if you want to
post a nasty comment on YouTube or
Twitter or Facebook you're telling
everybody that that's who you are yeah
you're basically telling everybody that
this is who I am I'm a person who sits
in my house and writes nasty things
about people and and the the thing is
the big challenge is is not to take it
personally when somebody says something
nasty and this is in life too that that
has more to do with them than it has to
do with you and you know my kid's
growing up in the digital age he's
already on the iPad ad and the phone and
everything and he's going to have a
Facebook page eventually and I have to
teach him that it's just words on a
screen and it's up to you how to
interpret that you can either take that
personally and really take it to Art and
let it hurt you or you can go it's just
words on a screen yeah yeah for sure I
think that you know uh the internet is a
great resource in that it provides
anonymity which can be used for good or
for bad right so people can say what
they will about you and you just what's
really important is to kind of set your
own Foundation within yourself to be
able to comments like that especially
when you make yourself like a public
figure um I fortunately have a super
super awesome Community online and
they're nine times out of 10 very very
positive and when there is like a
negative comment I got the other day I
posted a video about marriage being like
yay I'm so happy blah blah blah and this
guy says you know that so like a lesbian
she's the epitome of lesbianism which I
was like really oh my God you did it I
did it what is the epitome of lesbianism
I don't know cuz I've always nailed
it best exactly um he said she's the
epitome of lesbianism cynical uh one
other negative thing and that I didn't
want to have babies and I was like you
don't know that I want to have a baby
you can't tell me that are you kidding
me have you seen my hips like I am ready
for children yeah Johnny what about you
I'm sure now you put up some pretty
hypersexualized stuff online and that is
partly what they seem to be afraid that
we're all these like sex monsters we are
I believe I wish I was having that much
sex you know even I wish I was having
that much sex but so you must get a
particular brand to that because you're
putting out stuff that involves a lot of
naked people well I put out a lot of
videos that are extremely forward in
their gay nature I mean there's a lot of
rap videos out there with ladies
dropping it like it's hot and I'm an
equal opportunity
exploiter I feel it's very important
that because if I was a young gay teen
I'd love to be able to watch booty
videos of guys dropping it like it's hot
is very important yeah you're not a
young 18 and you still like it and you
can continue to like that through your
entire life the thing is I even put up
what I would consider one of my softest
most gentle videos recently it's a gay
pride Anthem called the gayest of all
time and still people were like that is
disgusting how can I was like how can
you look at this video where lesbians
and gays and trans all get together and
lips think a song about being the gayest
of all time how could you think that's
horrible and I say that to myself and
then I delete block see you later ho bye
bye yeah those are always
the funniest ones when they they attack
you for something that you love about
yourself like I see sometimes people be
like oh well he likes the Golden Girls
I'm always like yeah the best show ever
great ever what are we talking about
yeah chall you can't you can't please
everybody you can't even like we were in
a at the frameline festival just last
weekend we did a short film for kids
with LGBT parents and we posted it on
boing boing and somebody said and this
has features every single ethnicity in
it it's like me my husband and my son
we're like the last two minutes of It's
a small world I mean it's like I'm Asian
white he black everything we got
everything so somebody posted uh oh
typical they say they represent the
entire Community but they they don't
feature any trans or bisexual stories
and meanwhile our director and the
writer of it and the Creator is a
bisexual
transwoman so it's you may have to say
that slowly for some so a bisexual
transwoman is can you can you explain
what is uh a a person has transitioned
she was uh a m to F male to female yeah
transitioned and now she's living as a
female and she's bisexual and very
friendly and very friendly and and a
very talented filmmaker but uh it was
like it's that it's kind of you put
things out there and you you're never
going to please everybody and I think
there also exists a community of people
that that just live to kind of post
negative things yeah all right well
let's let's get get this to a positive
place because as I mentioned earlier
YouTube is doing their Proud To Love
campaign right now and people are
putting up videos using hash Proud To
Love about who they love why they love
what they love and that is exactly the
question that I'm going to pose to all
of you in order I have a sense we know
what you love Johnny but bring it anyway
I mean I would like to First say that
I'm proud to love all of America's tight
young muscular
gentlemen Lumberjacks military men truck
drivers tall man shorter man man with a
big thigh man with a juicy booty man
with a th strong forearm Johnny one one
one minute for answer sorry sorry you
have me a glass of water please but also
I would to tell you I'm proud to love
the gay family that we create for
ourselves that's something pretty
magical that gay people have been able
to do surround yourself with your family
so uh I'm proud to love all my gay
family I see you out there boo boo love
you
baby Hannah who or what or or how or why
do you this is like current events and
yeah I know I really like it um I'm
proud to love you know this is probably
not as good for me as it is but I really
really love cheese and I just every day
I think about it it's the first thing I
think about when I wake up um no but uh
in all seriousness uh and I have to say
this just because my community is so
good to me I love my online community I
love the group of herosexual that are
out there wanting to do good together
and impact the world in a positive
open-minded way yeah I do love too right
but cheese ultimately am I right cheese
lover is a bad name have you guys
noticed that gay guys usually don't eat
cheese in front of each other I feel
like lesbians are willing to eat cheese
this is the first time I've heard of it
you never where are you hanging out gay
guys don't eat bread in front of each
other cheese in front of your boyfriend
I know I've been spending too much time
in West Hollywood and Miss Whitney mixer
who or what or why are you proud to love
well I must say I agree with you I am
also proud to love cheese as well um but
I'm proud to love my wife and I'm also
proud at the fact that I can get married
again for the third time it's a charm
but now legally in this beautiful state
of California um you've been living as
an outlaw I have god it feels so good
living that's right um but I'm also
proud that we are reexamining kind of
our mentality on marriage and love and
what it what it means in this country
and um I'm proud uh that there are still
people out there like Wendy Davis who is
willing to stand for 13 hours straight
without king with a back brace for
something that she believes passionately
about yeah so and it all worked out cuz
they tried to sneak it in and make an
hour but it all worked out she did it
Alec mafa who did it or why or what what
are you proud of yeah uh I'm proud to
love my husband proud to love my son
that's a whole kind of thing that I
didn't imagine was possible when I was a
kid uh so the fact that I'm living that
dream is exciting to me every day I am
proud to be part of this radical
minority because it's always the radical
minority in America that pushes this
country forward it's never the majority
that wakes up one morning and goes hey
you know what let's free the
slaves hey you know what let's let women
vote that's a good idea it's always a
radical minority always starts off as a
small voice that knows what's true and
knows what's just and I'm really proud
to be a part of this moment yeah said
all
said all right Bri he got an Applause
break who are you proud to love or why
or uh what I am proud to love my parents
because they are the most amazing human
beings and I was so scared to admit this
part of myself to them and the way they
handled it I am just so proud to be
their daughter because my my dad we went
on a walk walk and he brought it up out
of nowhere and he looked at me and he
was like I was about to tell him and he
was like you don't have to say anything
and he just hugged me and he's like I
just want you to be happy it doesn't
matter who if and I was like okay I'm
the luckiest girl in the entire world
Applause for the dad right there tear
break single tear break little te find
of B all right well I guess I have to
answer this myself I I would say I'm
prouder more than anything else about
timing right right now we are in
something that is so cool the fact that
you guys whether you're gay or straight
or by or Trends or give me another one
robot queer questioning there's a lot of
letters the fact that it's actually it's
become cool that this thing that like I
feared my whole life that I think most
of us did that we thought was something
broken in US is actually cool now and
I'm with my Straight friends like they
actually think it's cool that I'm gay
and uh it's the sex also okay
now uh let's talk a little bit about
coming out Bri Bri got us there uh
because everyone thinks that it's always
this hard horrific difficult thing but I
think there are moments like bri is
mentioning and I most of my moments were
like that did you guys have some cool or
fun uh coming out moments Johnny oh uh
my parents were extremely liberal they
met in the Peace Corps they mentioned
gay marriage at their wedding in like
1971 so when I came out to my parents I
chose Christmas morning as you always
myself in a bow I have a gift for you I
like penis
um my my parents were really down with
it and my mother's first comment was I
just want to be sure that you have good
sex thanks Mom did
it all right pretty good Hannah what
about you coming out um yeah you know
unfortunately uh not super good um in
fact one of the bad ones uh but that
that being said I think that it's a
character building experience and um
there's always something that you can
gain from something like that uh I once
was at a panel um speaking on a panel
and the gentleman next to me said
something they'll never forget which is
that even if they don't respect you you
have to give give them the respect you
deserve uh and I felt like that was kind
of what you were saying Bri about you
know en counter hate with love um and so
yeah I think it's been good I came out
openly I'm 26 now I guess I was 22 um um
but I came out to myself when I was like
20 um and so that's that's kind of how
it's been yeah do you guys think that we
actually get something special because
we have to deal with this that it makes
you know we have this sort of secret
this this shame thing that when you
finally figure out who you are you end
up with a better sense of self like you
end up getting something really special
well you have to give yourself that
sense of self because when you grow up
as a as a heterosexual person your
sexuality is supported by the
predominant culture you turn on a
television it's it's okay to be who you
are it's great to be straight everything
is like you know that's and and
courtship is celebrated in fact your
parents are a part of that you know your
first date and everything and when
you're gay not so much not so much well
just suddenly you know what I think is
such a an interesting occurrence is that
when you start coming out to people and
the process of coming out never really
ends you come out every conversation
where you're like you're like oh so do
you have a boyfriend nope and girlfriend
actually um but what I think it's
interesting is that people who love you
and you love too will think that since
they didn't know this part of your
personality the other fundamental
aspects of you were going to change I
remember when I came out to my sister
she burst into tears and she was like I
just don't want you to just like become
some like
Lumberjack lesbian yada yada yada she's
like I like who you are yeah and it's
like this is this has nothing to do with
who I am on a superficial level this is
you actually look like the last person
on Earth who could like hack a tree down
I think well first of all I'm very very
strong sorry
a
lum that's right that's right I feel
like I need to come to your defense
thanks you can hack a tree a tiny you
can do it a little Charlie Brown
tree what about you this isting mental
image of myself just FYI I think uh I
think my coming out was actually coming
out of my mother into the world um no I
think at age about age six when I wanted
to be Billy Idol and be with Susanna
Hoffs that was pretty much a tell to my
parents you know I think um I think they
pretty much embraced it and and let me
look like Billy Idol as much as I could
at six years old being a girl in
Connecticut um but you know what my mom
always told me it doesn't matter if
they're purple with stripes as long as
they make you happy and she really
engrain that in and so I I think I was
actually in coming out and actually
saying it I was more nervous uh because
I felt stupid like it would be like the
equivalent of like a straight person
being like Mom Dad just let you know I'm
bringing home a girl like you know like
I'm straight it's it doesn't really uh
have a lot of weight I want it to be
more dramatic yeah before I get to you
guys on this question I think because
we're all somewhat public figures at
some level or we'd like to believe so at
least right you'd like to believe so
thought television every Thursday ATT on
AMC uh do you guys feel like you have
extra pressure you were on the real
lward and you were sort of like the hit
star of the show where did you feel
extra pressure that you you could not
let the lesbians down I cannot let the
lesbians down only myself and my family
that's really what happened um no you
know I think you kind of get this sense
of being a role model I would probably
not like to group myself into that
because I kind of uh was known as the
anti- maybe role model I don't know but
um I think it was just about like being
myself and being comfortable and showing
that and and I happened to be gay so
there you go lesbi so before I get to
you guys did did you guys do you feel
the same thing I mean with the videos
that you put out do you feel like
sometimes it's going to turn the Gaze
against oh he should clean himself up
and you know well I mean for me the
videos the biggest thing I get back on
videos is that people will now who are
now in their 20s be like your video
helped me come out when I was in the
closet in high school and that was just
me dancing around in Ryan Stone jeans
ping guys back and forth singing about
soccer practice but literally again and
again people like I was home everything
else was weird but I saw you you were
tough you were but you pushed those guys
around I thought wow I could do that too
I can be gay too I said you can gay but
see that it makes a huge difference I'm
on this reality show now where I travel
to tiny little towns out in the middle
of nowhere and in each every one of
those towns there's a gay person there's
a town
gay and and a lot of them are featured
on the show we have a lot of gay
contestants on the show and uh it
matters to them if you're in the media
and you're yourself I've gotten the big
comment I get from a lot of people in
small towns is thank you for being
yourself and when you see people who are
themselves on television and it empowers
people yeah about visibility and
relatability like you know yeah you know
what I think is just kind of interesting
this that reminded me of this is I I get
asked questions all the time from people
that are like why are gay people like
this so why are there gay people like
that like why do all gay men love show
choir or something ignorant like that
and what I always want to say back is
like there are way more gay people than
you realize um so certain personality
types are more comfortable being
themselves sure but that doesn't mean
that the there's not gay accountants
yeah but see you put your that you got
you know got it exactly it's like
there's way more gay people than you
realize like my my college roommate said
that I was the first gay person she ever
met and I was like really where'd you
grow up She said Long Island I said
listen look at your
yearbook
so we open up the yearbook and I go go
to the girl softball page and then she
went
oh get it so she grown up with gay
people her whole life but she didn't
know it it'll be really different for
our children you know they're going to
grow up in a world and it's not going to
matter your the your interests and the
people that you fall in love with are
not you know related in a direct way
yeah well you guys are giving me a
perfect segue because the next thing I
want to talk about is stereotypes
because we all suffer from them but we
you know in the gay community we do it
to ourselves a lot because you know
you're either a bear or you're an otter
it's a freaking Zoo nobody knows what
it's all about the body hair uh I'm an
otter yeah you're what do you I'd like
to say I'm an otter bear an aish Bear
yeah an otter for for the straight
people can you explain what an otter is
it's a younger well a bear would be a a
larger gentleman of the hairy
variety but if you're a larger gentleman
of the hairy variety and not large this
way so much you can be an otter for a
certain period of time what other
animals are there do you guys oh there's
the bear polar bear Asian bear is a
panda I heard oh yes a panda bear it's
like a pet zoo it's like a
beautiful with their a
lamb I thought you said clams wa did you
say wait did you say clams or Lambs
either say clams no they're all clams
conversation has taking a very strange
term all right well but lesbians we need
to come up with our own little Animal
Kingdom so start there's no lesbian
Animal Kingdom I don't know no I mean
there's starfish what's that you know I
don't I mean that's really not one but
it's just like a girl that lays there
like this
oh I don't know it boom headline
headline I've met a couple male star
exactly for the record that's not just
lesbians BT du that is not yes that is
not just a gay so back to stereotypes
but back to stereotypes so Bri you
probably get this from both sides no pun
intended that was just flying out no
it's the worst yeah yeah it's it's
really really hard because a lot of
people are like so when are you going to
choose and I'm like okay I chose like I
like everyone like I'm into all private
parts like I don't like whatever yeah
and it's just like really frustrating
cuz like I've dated people that like
guys who are just like okay so when are
you going to get this out of your system
like do what you got to do and I'm like
okay no it's over first of all second of
all it's like there's nothing to get out
of my system like this is what's
happening all the time like if you had
to cleanse it would just go away exactly
like like say I want to buy cleanse yeah
yeah like say say we're in a thre sum
like and I'm with a guy and I'm with
another girl like I'm just as into it as
the guy is like this is not for you dude
this is for us you know what I'm saying
like that's how it is got it so and
that's but isn't it so much more about
love than it is about sex oh you yeah
thank you for thank you for clearing
that up what do you guys think there
there seems to be this controversy that
girls can be by but guys cannot be by
you know girls every girl in college
kissing a girl making out with a girl
that's cool but guys yeah we were
talking about this a little bit earlier
is that I feel like it's more socially
palatable um and this is probably due to
much of the media we consume is shot
through like a male lens that a woman
would be bisexual because yeah that's
hot because women are hot and sex sex
sex um but then if a man's by it's like
oh well I don't know I mean I'm not by
you know that sort of thing but when it
comes to like gay families on television
I feel like it's more consumable more
consumer friendly to see two gay men
raising a family together than it is to
see two lesbians like I think lesbians
have this terrible rap of being not
funloving interesting warm people you
know and it's like oh two gay dads
that's silly and sassy and fun plenty of
gay men that aren't silly and sassy and
fun I'd like to consider myself one of
them this guy is a
but you you say you say I think
that that's true if those two gay dads
are raising a daughter I think things
get will go back to that weird
uncomfortable state if those two gay
dads on TV are raising a son you know
people start I just feel I I just feel
like it it goes back to um challenging
that male heteronormative kind of like
two gay guys raise a son yeah yeah kind
yeah you know is he going to turn out
gay automatically I think that but
most I know that's to me like people
even ask that question banan will you be
disappointed if your uh child turns up
he's already straight he loves boobs
like he will gravitate towards the
breasts in the room and he's like I'm
doing stuff that I never thought I'd do
I go to baseball games I don't care
about baseball okay first of all but I
didn't want my son to miss out cuz I'm a
big so I took him to try outs on
I'm learning so much it's tryy outs not
auditions they're not costumes there
uniform uniform right and it's not
rehearsal
it's whatever
so but I'm I'm at every game and I could
see the expectation of the other dads
you know like oh what's this kid going
to do and my kid smacks it out of the
park cuz he's his own person had nothing
to do I mean he'd be so much better if I
practiced with him
you just find a straight dad to well you
go I think a straight dad would
encourage it but like my my thing is
like the sport is for him to have a good
time and you know get out in the sun and
be
exhausted and not be on the computer I
mean that's what the sport is for but
you see the other dads at the team like
ah like get really get into it and
yelling at their kids like Focus ice
front and I'm like you know this is
t-ball I'd understand if this were a
ballet class but it's t basically just
putting them in years of therapy so
exactly but but it's it's the
expectation on our kids is weird cuz
like I should have been like my dad who
couldn't have been a bigger Macho
yeah Bri I feel like what
Hannah said is so true though like on
Modern Family you have like the silly
gay dads but then you have like a show
like The Fosters which is a great show
by the way a great show really really
wonderful but then you have and it's
sort of like the serious lesbian moms
and it's like not as fun and yeah and
why is that assass one's a cop and one's
a vice
principal all right well we got we got
one topic left and obviously this has
been an incredible week for the gays and
and you know it's only going I was about
to say it gets better it only will
continue to get better that's that's
become very clear to me so what do you
guys see as the future for the gay
movement I mean obviously there's some
legal stuff that needs to be done but do
you guys at all fear that once we get
equality once we're truly equal and all
that stuff that we will lose something
something as a community something sort
of special that that we have now I mean
there's definitely something to be said
for feeling like Alec was saying that
you're part of like a radical section
and we've got to hold on to our culture
and keep it going and keep our
Traditions going and then we just become
like everybody else you're afraid we're
going to be boring but gays are the
superior race so we'll continue to stay
Superior and create the most beautiful
things in the world yes I said it gay
power somehow we will figure out a way
to multiply because we're Superior there
you go what do you think but isn't it
about love and not sex uh no I mean I
think that the best thing that can
happen for people and it's not gay
people or straight people is that people
accept each other for who they are and
don't Place judgment or fear on each
other I'm hoping that we don't keep
calling it gay marriage how about we
just call it more marriage or marriage
um so yeah I'm I'm very pleased with you
know gay people becoming normal or
boring it's going to be like a no big
deal type of thing I mean to kids coming
out now I mean kids are giving you
calling all the basic and like
12 I mean basic I mean that's gay and
that's just becoming that thing like oh
you know that's how she be that's how
she be yeah whitnie what do you think
the future of the gays the future of the
gays uh you know I like that I can be
part of of an age an era when uh I have
kids I can actually say to them you know
when I was your age or you're welcome
cuz I made this a lot easier for you you
know and actually have something behind
it you know I like how you think your
child's going to be gay already well you
know
oops flip I guess Mother's Prayer yeah I
mean even if they're not I'm going to
find a reason to use that line um but
you know in reality I I think even
though we've obviously came a huge way
in the past 48 Hours um I think we still
have a tremendous amount to go and we're
we're we have all these states that
still need to be passed before it
becomes Federal hopefully and then we
still have issues surrounding kids uh
adoption you know some families still
have a hard time at gay parents adopting
kids out so I mean there's definitely
still Milestones to hit before we're in
the clear so we still have that you know
secret society of Gom that we can
maintain for a little while longer I
think now Alec you are married and have
a kid so you're sort of like a gay from
the future already I a gay from the
future future gay uh vodka is free in
the future uh now here's what happened
my son came to live with us when he was
5 years old and he was from he was from
Compton right and and we kind of set up
from the beginning were really clear
about the kind of family we were like
some people have two moms some people
have a mom and a dad you have two dads
and look at us we're all different I'm
Asian papa is cinjun which mean he's
from Louisiana so he's kind of French
and you're African-American but we all
fit together cuz we're a forever family
so my son dropped off at kindergarten
for the very first time and he's running
back to the car you know cuz we're
picking him up at the end of the day and
two little girls go sees the two dads in
the Volvo in the gay dad station wagon
right and they go you have two dads and
my son sign goes yes and the little girl
goes why and he goes cuz we're
French that was his takeaway cuz we're
French and the two other girls kind of
went and then went off and skipped to
the other direction so that's the future
going to be like oh okay it's just
another no big deal re future of gays bu
all the letters just wish that we could
stop using gay as an adjective to
describe people I feel like it's just
let's just be people and not have to put
that word in front of it yeah wouldn't
the point I guess at the end of the day
for us to not have to do panels like
this eventually and uh this will be a
thing of the
past exactly all right cool well I
really thank you guys for coming out and
doing this how about a round of applause
for what aight what a
host what a guy Bri estri Alec mappa
Whitney mixer Hanah har Johnny McGovern
I'm Dave ruin I want to thank uh The
Young Turks obviously who produced the
show and let me say what I want which is
all any comedian or gay person really
ever wants uh I also want to thank
YouTube for throwing this we are going
to have some drinks right now and uh and
a final thought uh the video that I
showed you guys earlier of my
grandmother she actually passed away
this morning and uh it's it's really
it's okay she lived a wonderful life and
taught me everything that you saw in
that video she taught me and uh to to be
better and to be kind and uh and now
it's time to drink so let's uh let's
have some fun thank you
guys